SORRY TO CAUSE FAMILY SQUABBLES.
>> Laura: THE 2020 DEMOCRATIC
FANATICS ARE KISSING THE RING
OF THE REVEREND AL AT THE
NATIONAL NETWORK CONVENTION
THIS WEEK.
>> WOULD YOU SIGN A BILL FOR
REPARATIONS?
>> YES, I WOULD.
>> WHEN I'M ELECTED PRESIDENT
I'LL SIGN IT.
>> ABSOLUTELY I WOULD SIGN THAT
INTO LAW.
>> WOULD YOU SIGN IT?
>> I FIRMLY SUPPORT THE BILL TO
CREATE A COMMISSION TO STUDY
REPARATIONS.
>> THINGS WE NEED TO DO IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT IS A LONG TIME
COMING.
ONE OF THOSE IS TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH REPARATIONS.
>> Laura: HERE NOW IS MICHAEL
MEYERS FORMER ACLU NATIONAL
BOARD MEMBER.
MICHAEL, YOU SAY THIS IS ALL A
SCAM.
EXPLAIN.
>> OF COURSE IT IS.
IT'S MORE OF THAT BLAME WHITEY
MOVEMENT MANIA, MADNESS.
AND RACIAL RHETORIC, THAT'S
WHAT YOU GET AT THE AL SHARPTON
SO-CALLED HOUSE OF JUSTICE.
YOU HAVE BEFOOLRY, DISTRACTION.
YOU HAVE THIS NOTION OF FARCE.
AT THAT HOUSE OF SO-CALLED
JUSTICE YOU HAVE EITHER A
HORROR PICTURE SHOW SHOWING OR
YOU HAVE A FARCE.
EITHER WAY IT IS NOT TO BE
TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
I CAN'T UNDERSTAND HOW SERIOUS
PRESIDENTIAL CONTENDER CAN GIVE
LEGITIMACY TO A RACIAL BLOW
HARD.
AND I THINK IT IS OUTRAGEOUS
AND SILLY  ON THE PART OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
IF ANYONE THINKS WHITE
AMERICANS WILL FEEL GUILTY OR
GIVE LAND AND PROPERTY AWAY IN
SOME SORT OF REPARATIONS POT
BECAUSE THEY FEEL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE SINS OF
THEIR FOREBEARS, THEY'RE NOT.
>> Laura: AL SHARPTON WAS
TRYING TO ADDRESS THE
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE ECONOMIC
STANDING OF AFRICAN-AMERICANS
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS AND HE
DISMISSED IT.
LET'S WATCH.
>> THEY ARE STILL DOUBLY
UNEMPLOYED TO WHITE.
TRUMP SAYS IT'S THE LOWEST
BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT.
HOW DO YOU CLOSE THE RACE GAP
IN WEALTH?
>> Laura: IT DOESN'T MEAN TRUMP
CAN CURE CANCER TOMORROW AND AL
SHARPTON WOULD HAVE SAID HE
SHOULD HAVE DONE IT A YEAR AGO.
>> I CAN'T TAKE AL SHARPTON
SERIOUSLY.
THE WHOLE RACIAL MOVEMENT IS
ANTI-IN--
>> Laura: HOW ABOUT THE 2020
CANDIDATES.
THEY PROSTRATED HIMSELF TO AL
SHARPTON.
>> I JUST DON'T GET IT.
IF THEY WANT TO BE SERIOUS THEY
SHOULD TAKE AL SHARPTON AND SAY
NO, THERE WON'T BE REPARATIONS.
WHERE IS THIS POT COMING FROM?
JAMES FOREMAN IN 1969 SAID WE
WANT $500 MILLION AND THEY WANT
IT FROM THE WHITE SYNAGOGUES
AND CHURCHES.
IT DIDN'T GO TO BLACK PEOPLE OR
DESCENDANTS OF AFRICAN-AMERICAN
SLAVES.
IT GOES TO PEOPLE WHO ARE
HUSTLERS AND PIMPS.
I RESENT IT AND I THINK IT'S
SHAMELESS AND RACIAL IDIOTS.
PEOPLE WITH INTELLIGENCE MUST
ADDRESS IT AS SUCH.
>> Laura: THEY SAY WHAT THEY'RE
DOING IS RACIST.
YOU ARE ACTUALLY SAYING THE GUY
WHO JUST CAME HERE FROM SERBIA
SIX MONTHS AGO SOMEHOW WILL
HAVE TO WRITE A CHECK FOR A
SOMALI REFUGEY WHO CAME HERE 20
YEARS AGO.
IT DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
>> IT'S UNINTELLIGENT.
NOBODY IS GIVING UP THEIR HOUSE
OR THEIR LAND.
NOBODY IS GIVING AWAY ACRES.
40 ACRES ARE GONE.
NOBODY -- NOT EVEN A BUILDING
IS GOING INTO THAT REPARATIONS
POT.
SO WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABOUT?
THESE PEOPLE ARE CHASING A
FARCE.
>> Laura: IT'S A CAMPAIGN ISSUE.
IT IS ALL A POWER GRAB, A TOTAL
DISTRACTION.
WE NEED TO HAVE YOU BACK.
WE'LL HAVE YOU BACK TO TALK